un seul façon d'implémenter quelque
chose d'équivalent à une zone
d'exclusion aérienne c'est d'envoyer des
avions de l'otan dont l'espace aérien us
craignant et d'abattre des avions russes
et cela pourrait mener à une guerre
totale en europe le président biden a
été clair sur le fait que nous n'allons
pas nous engager dans une guerre contre
la russie lynch
mais le refus de le temps d'entrer en
conflit ouvert avec la russie a été
sévèrement dénoncé par le président un
cogneur volodymyr zelensky il accuse
l'alliance de faiblesse et de se rendre
complice de bombardements sur la ville
ukrainienne le président au volent aux
émirats lenski
les gens qui mourront à partir de
maintenant nous aurons à cause de vous à
cause de votre faiblesse à cause de
votre désunion
aujourd'hui les dirigeants de l'alliance
atlantique ont donné le feu vert à la
poursuite des bombardements des villes
et villages ukrainien rendre refusant de
mettre en place une zone d'exclusion m